♪ ♪
>> Jesse: INSPECTOR GENERAL
MICHAEL HOROWITZ FACING OFF WITH
LAWMAKERS AGAIN TODAY OVER OVER
HIS REPORT ON THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
PRESSING HOROWITZ OVER
REVELATIONS OF FBI VIA SPIRITS
BECAUSE THEY.
JUDGE THE OUTCOME OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON INVESTIGATION
BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION ENDED
IN THESE EXACT FBI AGENTS AND
ATTORNEYS PREJUDGE THE OUTCOME
OF THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
BEFORE IT EVEN BEGAN.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THIS TEXT
SHOWS POLITICAL BIAS?
>> I THINK AS WE HAVE FOUND, IT
CLEARLY SHOWS A BIASED STATE OF
MIND.
>> PETER STRZOK SAID TRUMP IS
ABYSMAL, HE'S AN IDIOT.
HILLARY SHOULD WIN 100 MILLION
TO 0.
SOUNDS LIKE HE HATES THE
PRESIDENT.
>> HIS TEXT MESSAGES WOULD LEAVE
THAT IS THE IMPLICATION.
>> Jesse: HOROWITZ CONFIRMING
TO CONGRESS HE IS INVESTIGATING
WHETHER PETER STRZOK, ANTI-TRUMP
BIAS FACTORED INTO THE LAUNCH OF
THE BUREAU'S RUSSIA PROBE.
STRZOK'S LAWYER IS FIRING BACK
SAYING HIS CLIENT IS NOT A
CONSPIRATORIAL BUT INSTEAD,
READY?
A PATRIOT.
KIMBERLY, WE ARE GETTING WORD
FROM STRZOK'S LAWYER.
APPARENTLY HE HAS BEEN ESCORTED
OUT OF THE FBI OFFICE BUILDING.
>> Kimberly: I HOPE AFTER
LISTENING TO TREY GOWDY TODAY
THAT HE SPEED DIALED THE BEST
WASHINGTON, D.C., DEFENSE LAWYER
AND I MEAN THAT SERIOUSLY.
YOU LISTEN TO TREY GOWDY EARLIER
TODAY, IT WAS QUITE COMPELLING
AND PERSUASIVE.
HE WAS INSISTENT AND FIRED UP
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING.
I WAS LISTENING TO HIM.
WOW.
HE'S MADE THE CASE AGAINST NOT
ONLY STRZOK BUT COMEY AND
McCABE AND PAGE.
IT'S BAD, REALLY BAD FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
BAD FOR THE FBI, THIS IS SYSTEM
OF JUSTICE.
TREY GOWDY MADE THE POINT THAT
THERE CAN BE NO FAIRNESS IN THE
PROCESS WITH THIS LEVEL OF
INHERENT BIAS.
>> Jesse: VERY BIASED.
WE WERE LEARNING THEIR MORE FBI
AGENT SENDING ANTI-TRUMP TEXTS.
MAYBE ONE OR TWO OF THOSE
LAWYERS WOUND UP IN THE MUELLER
TEAM.
DANA.
THIS MUELLER TEAM IS PACKED FULL
OF THESE PEOPLE AT THIS POINT
AND THEY WERE REMOVED FOR
ANTI-TRUMP BIAS.
BY MUELLER.
THREE OR FOUR MONTHS AGO.
>> Dana: CAN I TELL YOU
SOMETHING?
I DIDN'T FOLLOW THAT PARTICULAR
PIECE BECAUSE I WAS FOLLOWING
IMMIGRATION ALL DAY.
I DID NOTE FOR TODAY
CATHERINE HERRIDGE SAID PETER
STRZOK COULD WILLINGLY TESTIFY
IN FRONT OF CONGRESS AT THE END
OF THE WEEK.
I WILL PAY ATTENTION TO THAT, I
PROMISE.
>> Jesse: GREG, WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THE IG HEARING?
>> Greg: I BELIEVE STRZOK'S
TEXTS ARE MORE INCRIMINATING IN
TERMS OF CONSPIRACIES THAT
ANYTHING IN THE RUSH OF
COLLUSION THINK THAT I WAS
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
WHAT WOULD BE COMPARABLE TO
WRITING "STOP TRUMP," WOULD BE
TRUMP TEXTING: CALL PUTIN.
WE'VE GOT TO STOP HITLER.
THAT WOULD BE THE SMOKING GUN.
THE BIG STORY TO ME AS ALWAYS
WHEN TO BE TREY GOWDY'S
EVER-CHANGING HAIR.
HE IS LIKE MARTIN LANDAU IN
MISSION IMPOSSIBLE.
HE'S GOT TO GO SOMEWHERE.
HE IS A RUSSIAN AGENT.
>> Dana: SAY CIA OR SOMETHING.
>> Greg: I THINK HE WORKS FOR
THE RUSSIANS.
>> Donna: NATIONAL MAN OF
MYSTERY.
I THINK THE BEARD IS VERY
BECOMING.
POLITICS SOMETIMES IS NOT SO
I ACTUALLY DID WATCH.
IT'S BETTER THAN WATCHING
SOAP OPERAS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DAY.
THE REASON WHY I WATCHED IT IS
BECAUSE UNDERNEATH ALL THE
PARTISAN RHETORIC ABOUT THAT, WE
LEARNED THAT ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE
AN AGENCY THAT HAS SOME
DYSFUNCTION.
WHETHER YOU FOCUS ON THOSE
EMAILS, TEXTS, DISGUSTING.
I'M A FORMER FEDERAL EMPLOYEE.
DISGUSTING.
LET'S SAY.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
WHETHER YOU'RE SAYING THOSE
THINGS ABOUT MR. TRUMP OR SAYING
THOSE THINGS ABOUT MRS. CLINTON.
THEY ARE NOT HIRED TO TEXT EACH
OTHER ABOUT THEIR PERSONAL
DISLIKE OF A PARTICULAR
CANDIDATE.
THAT BEING SAID, THE OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY MUST
NOW DO THEIR JOB AND REMOVE
THOSE WHO ARE STILL IN THE
EMPLOY OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
BEYOND THAT, I THINK THIS REPORT
TELLS US A LOT ABOUT MR. COMEY
STATE OF MIND, THE FACT THAT HE
WAS INSUBORDINATE.
HE BELIEVED HE ALONE COULD
DELIVER THE SO-CALLED MESSAGE TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DIDN'T HAVE TO CHECK WITH HIS
BOSS.
THERE IS A LOT TO LEARN IN THIS.
I HAVEN'T READ ALL OF IT BECAUSE
AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE NO
PICTURES.
I READ FASTER WHEN I SEE
BUT IT IS A STORY THAT WE NEED
TO KNOW.
BY THE WAY, YOU AND I CAN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE RUSSIANS.
I CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT OF THE
LANGUAGE NOW BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Greg: I AM MARRIED TO A
RUSSIAN SO I CAN SPEAK A LITTLE.
>> Jesse: SPEAKING OF COMEY,
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL CONFIRMS
COMEY'S HANDLING OF THE
CLASSIFIED MEMOS IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
EVERYONE IS UNDER INVESTIGATION.
>> Greg: WE WILL BE SOON.
>> Donna: CAN WE DO ANOTHER
KUMBAYA AT THE END OF THE
SEGMENT?
>> Greg: THESE THINGS ARE LIKE
SOCCER.
IT IS LIKE 0-0 AT HALFTIME.
IT'S LIKE SOCCER.
0-0 AT HALFTIME.
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
WAS A TIE.
I THINK IT WAS A SLAM DUNK.
>> Greg: THE NEXT ONE WILL
BE...
>> Donna: YOU WAIT UNTIL 1:38
AND THE GUY SCORES, YOU'RE LIKE
THANK YOU.